since negan played by jeffrey dean
morgan made his dramatic first
appearance on amc's the walking dead
it has been obvious he's not a good guy
good guys don't generally introduce
themselves by decapitating two fan
favorite characters
in gruesome fashion sure jeffrey dean
morgan brings a certain rugged charisma
to the role
and his scenery chewing dialogue has
long been a serious highlight
but underneath it all is a man that has
killed out of cruelty
sports and personal gain he's also lest
we forget his many wives
a serial coercive rapist his sanctuary
was a brutal totalitarian regime
governed by a keratin stick system of
physical punishment and monetary reward
the whole hierarchy was kept aloft by
fear before rick's alliance of survivors
took down the saviors
their society represented the most
extreme extension of a system
based on the flawed premise that might
makes right
so forgive us if we've always been a
little skeptical of the batman's i did
it because the apocalypse
rationalization
as the walking dead concludes its drawn
out 10th season fans have been treated
to a dedicated negan episode
that seems to confirm the worst about
negan's character
the cynics among the show's viewership
may have already written negan off as a
violent sociopath
but the latest bonus episode of season
10 pretty much
confirms for the rest of us that negan
had issues long before the dead started
climbing out of their graves
and munching on the living some people
are just wired wrong
and for negan the zombie apocalypse
served as more of an opportunity for him
to indulge his inner psycho than a
trigger
the episode entitled his negan based on
a side story from the comics that was
published in trade paperback
under the same name takes a look at the
character's origin story
the prequel tale reveals what the man
was like back when lucille played here
by morgan's actual wife hilary burton
was an actual woman instead of a
baseball bat wrapped in barbed wire
the verdict isn't great for the big guy
in the leather jacket
well negan may still get his shot at
ultimate redemption on the show
his character has one of the strangest
most bittersweet endings in the source
material after all
this episode proves that he was never a
man to admire
he as negan shows us a familiar sight of
negan in an unfamiliar environment
the former saviour's kingpin had always
relied on the paper-thin justification
that the post-apocalyptic world of the
walking dead required a brutal hand to
start arranging things into a shape
resembling the lines
of civilization once again it's all
there in the somewhat ironic name of his
group
the saviors were saving people from
zombies and societal collapse
at least that's what negan was telling
himself and any unfortunate captive who
had to listen
turns out negan's anger issues and
propensity to resort to violence
pre-date the appearance of the walkers
in here's negan the problems will start
while he's enjoying a pleasant night out
with his wife lucille
when a belligerent man at the bar talks
over a special song of theirs
lucille asks the man to lower his voice
the man proceeds to get in her face
instead and at that moment negan loses
his call and attacks him
post scuffle negan is fired from his job
as a gym teacher at the local school
where the man's kids attend he is also
sued and lucille then has to pay for her
aggressors hospital bills
because the beating negan dolled out was
so severe the scene pains a portrait of
how negan's malicious and vicious ways
come from a deep-rooted place in his
past
he's always been a little too quick to
resort to violence which many of us
already assumed one of the open
character questions that the series will
have to grapple with as it approaches
ascend game
is whether or not a man like negan can
ever truly redeem himself
we've seen plenty of redemption arcs
over the last 10 seasons of the walking
dead
in general the stressful conditions of
the zombie apocalypse allow us to be
generous with characters who have done
terrible things to survive
negan's a difficult case though just
because of the sheer scale of his
wrongdoing
since his incarceration negan has made
some pretty bold attempts to prove that
he's reformed his ways
first he refused to escape even when his
cell was left open and
unattended he also formed a bond with
judith even risking life on them to save
her during one of alexandria's most dire
moments
then he played a crucial if violent role
in helping bring down alpha's whisperers
the most virulent threat to the
survivors since well negan
anyone who was starting to come around
however is going to have to rethink that
assessment after watching his negan
potential spoilers here but in the
comics negan is one of the few
characters who actually survives the
final panel
in the final flash forward issue that
follows an adult cole grimes deceased on
the show
we get a brief glimpse of negan who has
been living a lonely life in exile
presumably since the whisperer's arc
concluded the man may have earned his
freedom by acting in the interest of the
community
but he never fully redeems himself his
isolated life is his ultimate penance
for crimes that can never be undone
we'll have to wait for the walking
dead's final season to see if it takes
negan in a similar direction
but the very fact that the show adapted
here as negan suggests that someone on
the creative team
wanted to remind us all that negan's
flaws run deep
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one